sounds very exciting and here we are at
5 18 on your Friday morning what's cool
at school when we mentioned this the
other day the Clark County School
District has its first electric School
Bus
well maybe today's report should be
what's cool getting you to school the
district says the average diesel fuel
bus cost about 60 dollars a day to
operate the electric bus 10 a day as
excited as the CCSD is about the project
and the Partnerships with NP energy
State's Environmental Protection Agency
in Clark County's Department of
environment and sustainability
superintendent Dr Jesus jarro says
they're especially proud of the men and
women who get behind the wheel to get
our kids and grandkids to and from
school and our bus drivers are the first
ones that our children see
and they are the last ones that our
children see every single day as we
operate the largest bus fleet in the
country and maybe that even includes the
photo opportunity for the superintendent
Dr Jara behind the wheel of the electric
school bus now that first bus going to
start taking kids to and from Cimarron
Memorial High School as well as cats and
Hollingsworth Elementary School sometime
in the next couple of weeks we always
want to know what's cool it's cool if
you got something let us know cool it's
cool under the Community tab at our
website or just email cool at school at
8newsnow.com